exactly one week after the tragic events  in Paris EU Interior and justice  ministers will gather in Brussels to  discuss reinforcement of external  borders discussions will focus on  increased checks at external borders the  Schengen information system that's an  alert system to identify criminals or  suspects at external border crossings  the European passenger name record also  known as PNR the automatic transmission  of data on airline passengers to the  country of destination the fight against  trafficking of firearms and terrorist  financing and appropriate judicial  response will also be discussed  you